bonsoir nous sommes jeudi à 30 juin vous
regardez le 7 8 le journal merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
l'actualité locale entouré de nous
inviter mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite les titres
la fusion entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine prend forme petit à petit
ce matin à nanterre le conseil
d'administration de le pays des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine se sont réunis
pour le vote du budget 2016 et la fusion
des sociétés d'aménagement explications
à suivre la 100e édition de l'open de
golf de saint quentin en yvelines
démarre aujourd'hui 26 français
prendront le départ de la 100e édition
de leur open national nous ferons point
sur place avec un autre journaliste
sportif michael et demi d'euros nous
parlerons également des retombées de
l'événement pour saint quentin en
yvelines avec jean-pierre seveste en
charge du sport pour l'agglomération et
daisy c'est le nom de ce lecteur pour
les malvoyants c'est une nouveauté à
plaisir la bibliothèque du château s'est
équipé de cet appareil qui permet aux
personnes malvoyantes et handicapés de
pourvoir alliés ou plutôt écouter des
livres audio est décédé nous y
reviendrons et aujourd'hui c'était une
opération recrutement au pôle emploi de
guyancourt qui s'est déroulée jusqu'à 16
heures
lagence a proposé un job dating à
plusieurs entreprises une opération
menée à l'échelle régionale puisqu'elle
s'inscrit dans le cadre des jeudis de
l'emploi le dernier jeudi du mois les
agences franciliennes organise ces
rencontres entre employeurs et candidats
cette fois le recrutement était axée
vers les publics dits sensibles les
jeunes les seniors et les demandeurs
d'emploi longue durée cinq entreprises
se sont prêtés au jeu
une quarantaine de postes étaient à
pourvoir pour une cinquantaine de
candidats on écoutait la responsable
céline saint joanis ne venaient plus de
précision elle était au micro de camille
lambert
l'intéressé qui doivent se présenter
très rapidement puisque les entretiens
sont de 15 à 20 minutes
et puis d'avoir accès directement à
l'employeur ce qu'il n'arrive pas
forcément à faire quand il envoie seule
leur cv ça s'inscrit en lien avec le
plan 500000 formation du gouvernement
donc qui prévoit l'entrée en formation
de 500 mille demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires qui grâce à cette
formation auront un retour à l'emploi
plus rapide et donc c'est pour ça que
nous avons favorisé également les
mesures pour l'emploi de type
préparation opérationnelle à l'emploi
contrats de professionnalisation et adam
individuel à la formation
je vous le disais en titre c'est une
fusion qui prend forme petit à petit ce
matin à nanterre le conseil
d'administration de le pays des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine se sont réunis
pour le vote du budget 2016 et la fusion
des sociétés d'aménagement
l'objectif de l'établissement public
interdépartemental permettre d'assurer
un meilleur service aux habitants
en commençant par la réorganisation des
sociétés d'aménagement des territoires
les précisions avec william l
l'établissement public
interdépartemental des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine est entré dans sa phase
opérationnelle
le conseil d'administration réuni ce
matin à nanterre a voté la fusion des
sociétés d'économie mixte des deux
départements
ce matin donc nous avons pris des
décisions importantes autour de
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire pour être
bref simple clair c'est la construction
de logements et d'équipements la
construction de logements pour loger les
yvelinois les alto séquanais et les
équipements qui vont avec ses
constructions de logements une nouvelle
structure a vu le jour ce matin site
alios une structure commune
d'aménagement dirigé par les élus locaux
ces missions ça va être de trop service
des communes en particulier et de leur
apporter toutes les compétences avec en
même temps
toute la réflexion que nous allons
conduire et qui sera une réflexion qui
sera plutôt dans une philosophie de
liberté des collectivités locales que
dans celle du la centralisation étatiste
dire est développé par grand paris
aménagement une fusion des structures
qui serait un premier pas vers une
probable fusion des départements
contestée par l'opposition
nous sommes pour des coopérations entre
collectivités
de là à aller jusqu'à la fusion il ya un
pas que nous franchissons pas parce que
aucun élu qui a siégé ce matin on avait
cette proposition dans son programme
à l'ordre du jour le vote du budget
primitif 2016 et la création d'un budget
annexe un budget light selon les
présidents d'un montant de 440 6000
euros réduit pour l'essentiel à
l'archéologie préventive
nous vous en parlions dans notre journal
le 20 juin dernier rappelez-vous les
agriculteurs avaient manifesté sur la
route nationale 12 contre le projet
d'implantation d'un centre leclerc hague
a lui la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial des yvelines a
tranché et vient de dire non à
l'implantation de ce projet sur la
friche industrielle près de la gare de
montfort au mére un vote à la quasi
unanimité
car sur les 11 personnes qui siègent à
cette commission 9 se sont prononcés
contre tandis que deux autres sont
abstenus depuis son annonce officielle
début 2016 et le dépôt d'un permis de
construire en avril dernier ce projet de
3500 m² à des suscité une forte
opposition
une pétition avait même a récolté plus
de 6000 signatures contre ce projet et
je vous le dise en titre nous allons
parler golf aujourd'hui avec la 100e
édition de l'open de france de golf qui
démarre donc que ce jeudi à saint
quentin en yvelines
plus de soixante mille personnes sont
attendues sur les greens pour voir les
26 français en compétition mais aussi
les têtes d'affiché comme reuil mcelroy
victor dubuisson ou encore alexander
levy je vous propose d'aller jeter un
coup d'oeil à cette première journée de
compétition
michael almy d'euros notre journaliste
sportif et sur place pour prendre la
température
oui flora nous sommes au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous sommes
avec paul hermitage le responsable du
golf national à l'heure paul cette
première journée et était vraiment
intense sur les greens absolument c'est
parfait un temps sur les greens et en
dehors des greens parce qu'on a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de monde au niveau des
scores c'est parfait on a un français
qui est qui dans le top 3 là pour le
moment et et tout porte à espoir que en
aura pas mal de français parce qu'il
joue plutôt bien sur le parcours oui les
français se débrouillent pas mal mais
tout à fait tout à fait largement au
dessus au mieux que la moyenne en art
henry nott stars qui nous a fait venir
un énorme public aujourd'hui donc ça on
n'a jamais vu autant de monde à jeudi le
premier jour du tournoi qu'aujourd'hui
ça c'est sûr justement on va regarder
les réactions sur l'avenue de rory
mcilroy bah ça représente une grosse
star un grand joueur qui a beaucoup
d'avenir
il a un bon swing déjà il s'énerve pas
beaucoup yard ses nerfs et sam aspire à
jouer
bon je suis content parce que c'est la
première fois que je les vois et sam en
six drummers à jouer dès qu'on a appris
la nouvelle il était décidé conviendrait
pour cet open de france
monfils en rêve depuis deux ans il a
même fait un devoir d'école cette année
sur aux règles mcelroy donc il était
évident qu'on pouvait pas rater cet
événement je dirais que ça représente un
modèle
l'exemple du sportif qui mais qui a
aussi que les bons côtés du sportif et
pour tous les mauvais côtés qu'on peut
voir dans d'autres sports bon en tout
cas paul ils sont ravis de voir rory
mcilroy ici à saint quentin en yvelines
oui oui nous gâte rien en étant là parce
que il est quand même comme vous dites
numéro trois mondial il ya un grand
tournoi un championnat du monde qui se
déroule en exactement en même temps sur
aux états unis mais il a choisi de venir
ici parce que c'est le centième open de
france parce que c'est le parcours de la
ryder cup dans deux ans c'est un repère
h pour lui aussi parce qu'on vient de
faire les travaux comme vous savez on en
a beaucoup parlé et il n'a pas joué le
parcours depuis 2010 et effectivement
nous on le sent dans tout ce qui est
vendu billetterie c'est un impact non
négligeable sur l'événement vous pouvez
chiffré cet impact
oui on peut vous donner des tendances
en pré vente c'est-à-dire les commandes
de billetterie sur internet en a vendu
40 % de plus que l'année dernière et on
est à peu près au niveau des ventes
aujourd'hui ce soir dans la totalité de
l'année dernière donc en trois jours qui
restent et çà vous pousse encore plus
peut-être attirer des têtes d affiche
oui bah c'est la preuve que ce type de
politique stratégie marche mais la
stratégie de l'open de france et de
privilégier tout le plateau c'est à dire
de ne pas à payer ce qu'on appelle de
prize money et pas payer les joueurs
pour venir va dotation est déjà très
élevé salle avoisine quatre millions
d'euros à chaque année
c'est d'ailleurs le tournoi le plus doté
sur le continent européen derrière un ou
deux tournois en angleterre donc c'est
pas notre politique pour le moment donc
il faut qu'on trouve les moyens de
garder cette relation comme actuellement
avec danny willett avec rory danny way
qui a gagné le premier majeur de l'année
le masters qui sont venus faire
l'honneur à la france cette semaine
et est ce que c'est le plus beau open de
france de l'histoire
écoutez ce serait mal placé de ma part
de dire oui pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
le plus beau pourquoi parce que on vient
de passer une période intense de travaux
sur le parcours
tout de suite derrière l'open de france
l'année dernière on a fermé le parcours
neuf mois très beau je le rappelle
oui c'est ça avec 130 personnes par jour
une dizaine d'entreprises qui
intervenait on a carrément bouleversé le
parcours est donc d'ouvrir le 1er mai
attendant les budgets en plus et avoir
un open six semaines après avec les
pires pluies qu'on n'ait jamais connue
ici aussi pour nous c'est une belle
récompense
cette première journée et les retours
sont positifs de la part des joueurs oui
très positif on a des retours
on a pas de retours négatifs on a des
très bons retours sur les changements du
parcours le changement sur le dessin
notamment sur le 4-5-1 le green du 1° du
cese évidemment on savait que c'était
humide parce que
comme on sait qu'il a beaucoup plu mais
les retours sont hyper positif il ya eu
beaucoup de choses sur les réseaux
sociaux hier soir le joueur sont
repartis après leur entraînement
ils ont beaucoup de tweets et des choses
vraiment sympa comme quoi c'est c'est le
un des parcours 6 mba le parcours qui
préfère dans l'année est un des plus
difficiles sur le plan sportif rory
mcilroy pour l'instant au 23e victor
dubuisson le français superstar ici à
saint quentin divine est également 23e
ils ont fait un score plutôt logique
ouais je pense qu'ils ont rempli leur
contrat de la première journée la
première journée c'est toujours un peu
difficile parce que effectivement il ya
la foule
deuxièmement port au riz par exemple il
a joué le parcours pour la première fois
hier après six ans d'absence donc et
c'est qu'une reconnaissance du parcours
avant le jour j et par an aujourd'hui
sera je pense largement dans le code
pour demain soir donc oui je pense
qu'ils ont rempli leur contrat se sont
pas éloignés de la tête
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire et ils
sont pas en tête non plus ce qui leur
laisse par la pression demain et si vous
deviez faire un pronostic sur cet open
de france
vous n'êtes pas gentilles parce que
alors je vais jouer qu'au repos et je
vais dire un français ok c'est noté
voilà florane peut être un fond c'est
gagnera l'open de france
selon paul hermitage merci michael alors
réponse ce dimanche le vainqueur
pourrait être connu aux alentours de 18
heures et nous continuons à parler à
swinguer et birdy en plateau dans notre
entretien avec notre invité jean-pierre
roth sevestre bonsoir à vous bonsoir
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à vous
appuyer un coup de poignard mais surtout
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge du sport alors c'est
un événement très important
cet open de golf cela fait 25 ans qu'il
est organisé au golf national quand vous
êtes un petit peu organisés c'est très
important bien sûr et c'est le centième
open de golf
donc c'est très important c'est très
important pour la communauté
d'agglomération nous sommes partenaires
bien sûr de la fédération française de
golf pour cet événement et je j'en viens
justement puisque j'ai passé une période
forte partie de l'après midi sur place
et c'est une grande réussite je pense
votre reportage de signal bien c'est une
grande réussite que cette première
journée pour un jeudi il y avait
affluence sur le sur les greens c'est
exceptionnel et c'est c'est très
important pour les retombées économiques
que nous pouvons avoir sur le sur
l'agglomération
je rappelle que nous avons également au
sein de nos services d'agglomération des
des secteurs qui permettent au sein du
développement économique et de l'emploi
et de l'enseignement supérieur
nous avons des possibilités après
rencontre avec les chefs d'entreprises
avec les promoteurs que nous pouvons
rencontrer à l'occasion de ce de cet
événement de cette compétition du
circuit européen très important très
importante nous avons l'occasion donc
ensuite d'accompagner les entreprises
sur l'agglomération accompagné bien sûr
pour son développement mais accompagnés
également pour certaines sociétés
nous avons promo paul justement vous
avez une tente une loge là bas donc
c'est l'occasion justement de de nouer
des partenariats avec les entreprises
qui sont également à sur place bien sûr
c'est l'occasion de louer des contacts
d'avoir des contacts avec les différents
chefs d'entreprises qui peuvent se
rendre bien sûr sur le sur l'événement
et puis les promoteurs qui peut chercher
également des occasions des opérations
des projets sur sur l'agglomération
donc c'est l'occasion au cours de ces
journées de rencontrer différents
acteurs économiques qui sont très très
importants pour l'agglomération
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de de
s'endormir il s'agite toujours d'évoluer
et d'avancer dans nos projets
économiques très importants sur le
territoire avec notre projet de
territoire qui doit être élaboré d'ici
quelques mois c'est une superbe vitrine
soixante mille personnes sont attendues
sur tv est non il y aura forcément voilà
donc des retombées économiques aux
alentours au niveau du tourisme ce qui
vous avait anticipé cela également oui
il y a effectivement des retombées sur
le
sur le lan vironnement sur
l'environnement au point de vue accueil
point de vue hébergement au point de vue
restauration nous avons bien sûr
anticipé ceci mais nous avons également
dans nos projets c'est de thunes c'est
une répétition par rapport à la ryder
cup sur sur le dimanche et à la ryder
cup c'est à peu près entre 60 et 70
personnes qui sont attendus chaque jour
elle aura lieu en 2018 tout à fait parce
que demain c'est presque demain nous
avons une réflexion nous avons un comité
de pilotage effectivement un comité
pareil avec european tour pour
l'organisation de cet événement ryder
cup et bien sûr notre prochain notre
prochaine échéance son golf mais il ne
faut pas non plus oublier notre
candidature sur les jeux olympiques 2020
nous car ça peut vraiment vous renforcez
vous aider ça plaît bien sûr droit force
et nous aider pour les jeux olympiques
la candidature de paris 2024 bien sûr
sûr avec notre golf national et
l'organisation de l'open de golf
régulièrement sur notre gueule
bien sûr alors vous avez déjà eu
l'occasion de vous entraîner avec eux
les championnats du monde au vélodrome
l'année dernière là aussi c'est une
autre répétition
est-ce que du coup on peut imaginer qu
aura d'autres infrastructures qui vont
sortir pour d'autres grands événements
sportifs ou alors d'autres grands
événements sportifs nous avons
effectivement le golf le vélodrome mais
nous avons également pour les jeux
olympiques 2024 nous avons en projet
l'aménagement également de la colline
d'elancourt pour accueillir les épreuves
de vtt
donc il a également il ya une réflexion
et un aménagement du site envisagé pour
l'accueil des jeux olympiques 2024 et
autour du cou on pourrait imaginer
peut-être plus d'hôtels plus d'accueil
peut-être des respirations également il
y a c'est l'occasion l'occasion
d'améliorer notre nos infrastructures de
tourisme nos infrastructures d'accueil
en hébergement restauration
bien sûr sk déjà cet événement ça crée
de l'emploi sur 50 ans l'événement créé
de l'emploi
l'événement créé de l'emploi ne serait
ce que pendant l'événement lui-même mais
je pense que ça crée de l'emploi
également indirectement puisque nous
rencontrons des chefs d'entreprise nous
rencontrons des promoteurs nous
rencontrons des gens
qui veulent créer sur l'agglomération et
je pense qu indirectement il faut créer
de l'emploi et ça doit créer de l'emploi
vélo il ya aussi le golf c'est un peu
des sports qui se démocratise mais qui
sait quand même et l'itif élitiste vous
pour s'attirer vélo n'est pas très juste
à vélo sur piste
j'ai fait beaucoup de vélo et je
considérais pas cela comme un sport et
wifi mais du coup le golf ça que ça tire
la bourre aux entreprises ces cinq ou
six et nous visons ceci mais ça ne
m'attire pas seulement les grosses
entreprises et nous avons effectivement
aussi sur sur l'agglomération nous avons
à l'étude
ski club qui permettra au coeur de au
coeur de l'agglomération d'avoir un un
paul dike d'incubation d'entreprises de
d'entreprises innovatrices en
développement en laboratoire
alors vous même vous êtes à charge et a
donc dû sport pour l'agglomération que
depuis cette année est ce que votre
ambition c'est de donner une dimension
plus importante aux sports dans
l'agglomération que ce soit sur des
grands événements pas des plus aisées
lannion mon souci effectivement c'est de
favoriser les grands événements nous
avons et nous n'avons pas citer les
championnats d'europe qui doivent se
dérouler d'ici trois mois
au vélodrome les championnats d'europe
de cyclisme sur piste
mais il ne faut pas oublier à côté des
grands événements nous avons des
associations sportives au sein de
l'agglomération et qu'il convient
également d'aider et bien sûr il nous
faut également favoriser le haut niveau
car nous avons les jeux olympiques
justement 2024 et pourquoi pourquoi pas
favorisé le haut niveau pour l'accès aux
jeux olympiques pour nos athlètes
bien sûr d'autres infrastructures sur le
sur l'agglomération je pense que j'ai
cité la colline d'élan pour ela
actuellement nous sommes
il n'y a pas d'autres projets pour
d'infrastructures sportives c'est déjà
très important alors l'open de golf
c'est jusqu'à dimanche ou même vous et
vous serez présent mais il coûtait
j'étais présent cet après midi je serai
présent demain
demain une bonne partie de la journée
également et puis dimanche je serai
également une partie de la journée sur
le sur le parcours si vous avez une
petite préférence par rapport à des
joueurs ont écouté victor dubuisson bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr merci beaucoup aux
gens terre à semestre et c'est moi qui
vous remercie
merci bonsoir bonsoir et partons à
présent en vallée de chevreuse vous
plaît pour plus précisément à saint
lambert mardi soir le nouveau centre de
séminaires port-royal complètement ou
presque entièrement rénovée a été
inaugurée rire inauguré pour l'occasion
il a même été baigné ce n'est pas une
façon de parler l'évêque de versailles
monseigneur lemonnier était sur place
pour effectuer ce rite pas c'est
inhabituel pour un lieu regardez du coup
c'est le prium service qui n'ont vu
aujourd'hui ce lieu une réouverture sous
les meilleurs auspices après un an de
travaux le centre de séminaires port
royal situé à saint lambert a été
inaugurée
fondée à l'origine en 1964 par les
moines bénédictins
le lieu a été béni par l'évêque de
versailles bénéat dieu bénis dieu dit du
bien de nos dieux fait du bien et au
fond les personnes et les lieux
j'allais dire toute la création est béni
par dieu et tout avait créé à sion est
appelée à bénir dieu le lieu a été créée
par cette communauté religieuse un
prieuré est toujours situé à côté de ce
centre très attaché aux valeurs de la
religion chrétienne
d'où la bénédiction c'est un beau geste
c'est le centre appartient à une
communauté religieuse les
assomptionnistes et pour marquer notre
appartenance à cette communauté on a
demandé à notre évêque monseigneur
aumônier de venir pour marquer cette
transformation du centre
voilà donc c'est un geste fort le centre
pas royal dispose d'une dizaine de
salles de réunion et d'une cinquantaine
de chambres
il sera prêt à accueillir de nouveaux
séminaristes dès le milieu du mois
d'août tout autre sujet à présent c'est
une nouveauté à plaisir la bibliothèque
du château s'est équipée du lecteur
daisy avec une prison un simple et
adaptée
l'appareil permet aux personnes
malvoyantes et handicapées de pouvoir
lire ou plutôt d'écouter
livres audio mais également à décédé
depuis avril deux de ses lecteurs sont
accessibles au grand public c'est
camille lambert qui vous en parlera le
regard des chapitres 19
une chaîne en 1963 daisy c'est le nom de
cet appareil un outil adapté pour
répondre aux besoins des personnes
handicapées ou malvoyantes le lecteur
permet d'écouter un livre sonore ou un
cd à plaisir la bibliothèque du château
s'est équipé les touches elles sont
conçues vraiment pour le touché donc si
la personne veut arrêter les secteurs
il suffit d'appuyer et surtout
l'avantagé qui parle
et si je veux leur maître donc en route
et reprend exactement au même niveau où
je me suis arrêté régler le débit de
lecture revenir à une phrase passée de
chapitre en chapitre
autant de fonctionnalités accessibles
facilement en partenariat avec
l'association valentin haüy la
bibliothèque possède deux lecteurs daisy
les agents souhaitent les présenter au
public
nous allons en faire aussi des
démonstrations prochainement à la maison
rousseau qui est un club de 3e âge pour
le troisième âge sur la ville et à
l'hôpital de gérontologie sur la ville
notre objectif c'était sain d'aller vers
ces publics empêchés sont non voyants
malvoyants mais ils ont envie de lire de
continuer à être dans un pied dans la
culture un pied dans la lecture on est
là pour ça avec le service maintien à
domicile de la ville la bibliothèque il
peut également prêté le lecteur aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
la médiathèque de l'association valentin
haüy dispose d'un fonds de 20 mille
livres audio daisy si les retours sont
positifs la bibliothèque de plaisir
prévoit d'investir dans des appareils
supplémentaires et on se quitte avec un
mot sur l'euro 2016 ce soir le portugal
et la pologne s'affrontent pour le
premier match des quarts de fil à des
quarts de finale par dont le vélodrome
de marseille les accueillera à 21h
quaresma avait sauvé son équipe face à
la croatie la semaine dernière les
supporters portugais résidant dans les
vignes sont confiants mais surtout
impatient écouter les ils ont répondu à
patrick jacques de dixmude
on a hâte de voir le match et on espère
qu'on va gagner un ça va être serré mais
c'est jouable
2 0 pour nous but de ronaldo en première
mi-temps correspond en deuxième parfait
confiant confiant je pense qu'on deux
buts de charisme à un but de ronaldo
font chaque poste à pourvoir
c'est la fin de cette édition je
remercie de nous avoir suivis demain
vous retrouvez votre journal de fin de
semaine présentée par wilfrid est riche
avec l essentiel de l'actualité mélanie
poké vous donnera des idées de sorties
avec ses invités dans le 7 8 e week-end
quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi pour
une nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite donc une très bonne soirée et
un excellent week-end
tous